[Music]
welcome back to another off the record
with the careful boys today we got tesh
with us hey and we're gonna do a whole
session of ask an indian man
so it's because you know what's crazy is
like i've been around indian culture i
have indian friends whatever but i never
did like a deep dive of like asking
things that i was always curious about
because off camera we were talking about
um
you know punjabi and seat culture and
stuff like that and i was like wait i've
heard of punjabi like punjabi mc and i
was like is that another way to say
indian or is that like a cultured
ethnic group in india yeah it's an
ethnic group it would be like saying oh
you know i'm a
it's not as specific but like i'm a new
yorker and you're you know from
california oh
but we speak different languages we have
different cultures we have different
food angelino certain different certain
customs are slightly different would it
be almost like latin america like you
have the different like panama guatemala
whatever and they're like latin but they
yes and no because you know they they
all speak spanish
so like punjabi is different from tamil
where i'm from which is south india like
is it like china where there's cantonese
mandarin yeah like punjabi and tamil are
completely different like i can't
understand punjabi at all wow but like
punjabi is similar to hindi hindi is the
not you know the national language of
india so everyone speaks hindi like
everyone speaks mandarin they're
supposed they're supposed to do you
speak candy no i don't so like for
example like my dad doesn't speak hindi
my mom does
oh and so when they watch bollywood
movies we'll have to put we put
subtitles on obviously so they're just
speaking that's the english is their
common language well tumble they both
speak double oh
so the subtitles are they wouldn't read
in them my dad would probably now prefer
to read in english
that's pretty funny
what's like the most i guess dominant or
or biggest like culture group so you got
uh uh hindi you got tamo you got yeah
punjab you have yeah i would say i don't
i don't know probably punjabi southeast
you know south indian tamil
the central maharashtrian that's like
central which one's the the dad beats
the sun's ass yeah the dad beats the sun
all every oh what about the sun beats to
that brown culture
hindi speaking or even spanish speaking
if you're brown like your chat is
probably
because growing up my best friend was
indian but i think it was also like
we were so young you don't really dive
into
like knowing that there's differences
yeah of course yeah i just know i go
there when he's in trouble
his dad does wear uh like a head wrap of
some sort so he's probably see he's
probably see
his dad beats his ass and i know in in
the backyard her mom i mean his mom has
a ton of like lavender peppermint like a
ton of herbs that's all i remember and i
just remember if we run through the
backyard we're going to come out
smelling funny
top three childhood i mean it's better i
mean i mean smelling like lavender is
not so bad that's pretty fired yeah it's
pretty good people pay money for that
but like you know like sikhism is
actually it's a religion that's not uh
like you can be seek and be you know
white oh so there's no contact where
it's like that's mainly in india well i
would say the concentration
of people who practice sikhism are
punjabi oh
and and the mom and the grandma wore the
traditional clothes
where the the six-pack showing
but the sister
wearing regular clothes the auntie
midriff
a muffin available
i'm trying to explain it like western
trip there's a there's a halter top i'm
the wrong person are you familiar no
this is fun this is like a lenga which
is an indian skirt but maybe they're
wearing like something called several
gummies which is like a full outfit are
you familiar with cerritos and artesia
yeah okay so the the mom and the grandma
shops in artesia yeah it makes sense i'm
pioneer yeah so the sisters shop at the
mall because okay so those it's like
yeah it would be like your mom going to
chinatown to buy her club yeah yeah yeah
and then you hitting up macy's yeah down
the street
but they're over at sonachandi
yeah like what is that all about is that
it's just because they can get
traditional clothing there probably for
a price and they obviously can haggle oh
you know the haggling is it's hard to
figure out is it like every indian
community anywhere in the world is
haggling unknown like you can haggle
yeah you can haggle what are some no
haggle stuff yeah yeah there is no
situation oh really if you go to
other than like a restaurant where
there's like prices on the menu like you
know you don't see a price indian
patients haggle with your dad when after
they get like a procedure
you know
my dad haggles with the insurance
company
but uh yeah so you know indian indian
culture is very diverse you know even
with definition please
um which if you haven't seen on netflix
it's very good it's out
now right now watch it that's the movie
definition please 100 on rotten tomatoes
on netflix in the united states canada
uk new zealand new zealand and australia
australia let's go
so i have another question too um i
don't know if this is indian related but
what's your skincare routine i feel like
indian people have immaculate skin yeah
skincare routine so i'm gonna get yelled
at by everyone i wash my face with saint
ives which every single person that is
either like a dermatologist or an
esthetician is like don't use don't use
it what's wrong with that so that means
that
it says that you just like say that's
facebook is it the apricot one yeah the
apricot what's wrong with that we use
curology
they say that the walnut shells are too
abrasive well look at them we can't
argue with results come on dude you have
the best skin i've ever seen thank you i
just uh
one of my buddies stayed over
he brought over a face wash i don't know
what company it's from i've been using
that because he left it in my shower
is it lubriderm
sounds like a brand new that's like
that's like i thought that was lotion
thanks hearing you left it in my shop
mine now maybe also an executive
producer on the movie oh
what up that's what i do i wash my face
all right there's no secret it's just oh
i got a question uh indian question
genetics uh sunblock oh yeah sunblock
that's a big indian question number five
all right so uh
uh sri lanka that island right is that
considered india too or sri lanka used
to be part of india
uh used to be called salon and then they
changed their name sri lanka because i
think independence or whatever yeah
reflects and then they became
independent
um but they are now an independent
country but to answer your question he
used to be part of india as was pakistan
so like that's nationalism right but
then like what about ethnically so
ethnically they have i think the two
biggest groups there and
you know internet can look this up but
it's probably like sinhalese which is
like people from sri lanka and then and
then people uh who are thermal which are
people from my city oh because
south india yeah it's like south india
so it's like a larger area within the
groups of indian oh they're like these
other guys are late all the time
that group is called all india
indian standard time indian state and
standard time whatever acronym you want
to place on it dude if you want an
indian person to say oh my party show is
at 8 00 pm you tell an indian person 6
30 oh 6 30 6 30. hour and a half hour
and a half at least an hour holy [ __ ]
yeah bro what are you doing people doing
when they're late what are they really
doing are they right
having sex there's a billion of us
in la is there any beefs between indians
and bangladeshians
social beefs like little things i'm sure
they're i'm sure there are but like yeah
that i'm not privy to another country i
believe that was part of india before
the partition yeah because i think i
don't know
because i always like hear little things
like yeah i'm sure there's always like
you know cultural
rivalries i'm sure as there is in
regions of china of course like what you
know like people are like which who's
cooking is better sejuan or cantonese
yeah like you have [ __ ] like that right
i'm sure yeah
like so like north indian food and south
indian food are very different right so
like north indian food is probably what
most people are familiar with naan
chicken tikka
chana masala
like a dog paneer so all of that food is
very punjab great it's all punjabi food
that's why a lot of people you know know
punjabi culture yeah what about mango
chutney yeah but that's like basic
that's like me saying chili oil oh so
everyone like everyone does it right but
like everyone have their version okay
right right like everyone have don't be
regional versions but like south indian
food what i grew up with was like uh
dishes like dosa which is a lentil and
uh rice crepe savory crepe is that the
it comes in like little cups kind of and
then no so you're probably thinking of
sambar which is served with dosa idiot
oh you cups oh you're thinking of honey
pouring yeah yeah where it's like a
little yeah those are rice wafer they
poke a hole very good it's a little
potato and they put spiced water in it
i'm sorry right i [ __ ] up
so panipuri's like spiced tamarind water
whatever yeah that's whatever that is
and so that it means
the vessel the cracker the wheat cracker
and then pani means water
in hindi yo it's funny my girlfriend um
grew up in the uk right so she's like
man i'm so homesick right now can we get
some indian food yeah yeah yeah dude it
was so funny i was watching a cooking
show on netflix and it was in the uk
and it's like families that cook
against each other and they were like
okay so today you're going to make your
favorite dish from home right and i'm
like oh cool we're going to get like a
french dish an italian dish spotted
everyone made [ __ ] indiana
every single family meeting did it look
good and i was like what the [ __ ] is
today's video is brought to you by
audible alright so 2022 is a new year
and i think a lot of people are getting
on this like self awareness self help
just self work because we've been
changed positive change and a lot of
self
growth because we had a lot of time with
ourselves this past year you know what i
mean
and um i got on this whole thing and you
know how like we've been doing a lot of
road trips and uh there comes a time
when you don't want to talk all the time
in the car you just want to just listen
to something nice you know maybe
something together or something yeah
educational whatever and right now um
i'm listening to this audiobook called
thou shall prosper
and it's interesting because it's about
the rules and things that help the
jewish community like build their bond
build their businesses and like they
have different rules right and i feel
like i'm a secular person right i used
to be a part of a religion but then
sometimes i kind of miss
those things that make a you know
culture around the religion and and it
makes like a community and it makes
people like you know disciplined and and
maybe even like strict on themselves or
whatever yeah and then so i picked up
this book because i wanted to see like
oh a look into you know the lives of you
know the jewish community and
what they do to like prosper and things
like that and then so that's kind of
what i've been in it's been super dang
interesting yeah i really like
audiobooks too because a lot of times
you know when you're busy it's hard to
fit in
reading so if you're driving around a
lot especially we live in l.a or even
vegas where we commute all the time
listening to audiobooks on audible is a
very easy way to learn and have
self-growth and kind of improve where
your life is going and they got
thousands of titles too so if you're not
just into audio books they also got
podcasts guided wellness they got
comedies yeah theatrical stuff they got
all kinds of stuff for all of your
listening pleasures so it's freaking
awesome and it's an app you can just
have on your phones you can go anywhere
and listen so if this sounds interesting
to you make sure you go check it out go
to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 that's audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 and improve yourself i would
even say i would say yes but it's even
bigger wow it's like deep in the cold
it's deep because i would say like
british culture to indian culture is
almost akin to like american culture is
to black culture oh i see
also in the relationship
because like how they were persecuted
you know like indians were persecuted by
the british you know they took over
india i see you know what i mean so
they're much more intertwined it's super
complicated
obviously i'm american so i can't speak
as like a british indian but try though
it's [ __ ] up i'm gonna just go ahead
and say we can all agree it was all
[ __ ] up
from my understanding though is like you
know on the west coast right like if you
if you think about japanese americans
here being like six generations in or
whatever right out in uh the uk it's
even longer than that indians been
living out there for like a long long
long time a long time also it's like
much closer if they're like hey i'm
gonna get out of india let me go to the
uk just because it's shorter chances are
there's more community there's uh you
know just maybe i have a relative there
like whatever the reason oh but it's so
cold i don't know my parents moved to
new york oh that's true that's true do
you feel like upset when you go to
indian restaurant and the cooks are
mexican
no not at all
yeah we don't either no
then i know it's legit dude mexicans
make the best
worldwide worldwide everywhere you go
most well-rounded you know what you want
to know a funny thing if you go on a
cruise and you look at all the cooks
they're all like filipino indian or
asian or east asian the majority of them
are great
indian chefs yeah so like and they won't
serve the indian food but if you go and
ask them for it if you ask them for it
excuse me they'll get excited and
they'll be like oh yeah we'll make
something for you because you're there
for a week right or two so you just like
befriend one of the couple of people and
be like yo hook me up a little bit of
food
like just hook me up with the best
indian food you guys got and they'll do
it next carnival cruise bro because dude
a lot of people a lot of people don't
realize this but people who come in with
dietary restrictions so like oh i'm
vegan or i'll like i'll eat kosher or
like though instead of saying oh we have
kosher food they'll just be like oh we
just made you something vegetarian right
was indian food nine times out of ten
honestly as far as like this is what
people don't understand and i wish
people in america understood this and
there's like ob or american beef i like
beef yeah american food me too duh they
don't know how to cook vegetables beer
yeah that's true that's true like
steamed broccoli that's [ __ ] like if
you talk this is what i would say like
just put in a pot asian cuisine knows
how to cook vegetables i could be
vegetarian if i made chinese indian
cuisine like some of my favorite food is
indo-chinese food
which they is very popular in india
really yeah they basically take uh
chinese cooking techniques and use like
indian spices
also it's like southeast asian style
yeah yeah like malaysia yeah malaysia
it's also like malaysian food is very
because they get a lot of the influence
yeah yeah yeah yeah the sauces and the
breads and the cooking techniques and
it's like i love banana leaf at the
[ __ ] grove
is there even a proper indian fast food
chain no not out here at least because
you're thinking about jollibee weren't
you filipino
what's the equivalent like yoshinoya you
have panda express
they need one it
they just shoot out samosas at you it's
like kfc no they have like the street
vendors right so like like right like so
if like you want samosas you go to the
street vendor you want what we call what
about in america but they should make a
franchise like like curry kid or
something you know but it's never it's
her
here's the issue here's the issue curry
kids this is what i don't understand
like maybe you relate to this is like
when you go to people i'll never get
this you go to like a thai restaurant
you're like no not spicy i'm like get
out yeah so if someone came to me and
they were like hey i want chicken tikka
but like not spicy i'm like get out
because it's not the i'm like that's not
the dish it's hard to make spicy like it
has to be spicy spicy though
get out dude get up
cause sometimes man you get diarrhea man
yeah no i'm not saying like light it on
fire
but nine times out of ten i mean indian
cooking because it's so
spicy spice and like yeah yeah and like
labor intensive i mean i guess in the
fast food setting it could work but
indian people won't go there right so it
won't be authentic yeah oh that makes
sense like the restaurants i go to the
least are indian restaurants and i feel
like that happens with a lot of india it
won't have the fubu effect like i don't
know you guys go to eight like you know
asian restaurants i like one out here um
it's called banu one of my favorite ones
but they have a cool little bodega next
to it too but did you guys grow up with
authentic
you know the authentic i wouldn't know
what authentic is
of my culture yeah yeah yeah i lived in
a japanese neighborhood and so like but
would you have japanese food at home
every day home cooked my mom couldn't
[ __ ] cook for [ __ ] so i love the
restaurant
so like we had indian food
single day and you want to try other
[ __ ] it's not even that it's because it
can't beat you you can't beat home food
like you can't beat it and like all of
our friends we all operate the same and
like we'll go to indian restaurants
together and be like yeah it's whatever
yeah interesting have you had indian
food in the uk because it blew my mind
it's i'm like why can't they do this in
america no but i've had indian food in
india oh yeah and it's it's great it's
yeah oh yeah it's different it's
different and it's excellent it's
[ __ ] excellent it's also like a
fraction of the price i'm like that
makes it even taste i spent like five
dollars damn all this food like for all
of us to go eat like kings i could spend
literally 20 bucks and it would be more
than anything we've ever seen
like if we went to like small hole in
the walls what's the best indian street
cart food um
like in l.a i mean or in india like what
what's that
you can't eat it like i can't eat it
because then i'm going to have dysentery
like when you see like andrew zimmerman
will go down
like these these youtubers who go to
these food carts all those guys grow up
there or you know there's like those
those famous white guys right there they
like live in china or live in thailand
or live in india so like they're okay
drinking the water like i can't go have
pony pory if i go have pony pory i'm
gonna die
like i'll have diarrhea for three and a
half weeks yeah because you have to see
them boil the water or cook the food
right you have to like watch so like
even if they're like hey i want a samosa
from street vendor they'll have 100
samosas sitting in a pretty triangle
right and they'll be like flies on it
right and like [ __ ] like that you have
to be like no you need to make me a
fresh one i need to see you make it and
then they're just like this [ __ ] guy
and even then you're like is it a risk
because like the potatoes have been just
sitting out there i've eaten a lot of
food like that and i'm fine but the last
time i got [ __ ] up was at a marriott
eating mexican food in mexico in america
not in america not like i would get
donuts from a guy that has a [ __ ]
donut basket he opens up and flies fly
out and i'm all like i'm eating that
[ __ ] you kind of got to pick your
poison like one time i had a chicken
shawarma sandwich and it was literally
an auntie squatting on the floor like
she had her sari hiked up and she was
like stirring the pot and i looked over
at my cousin and i'm like dude are you
sure this is gonna be okay and he's like
yeah it'll be fine and then i saw the
one dude like pull a baguette out of
like a [ __ ] the back of a rickshaw
and i was like i don't know if i should
eat that
and then he had this sauce and he just
put it all over the baguette and i was
like yeah i think i'll eat it
and you were good and i was fine and
ironically dude i was the only person on
that trip because my whole family's
there that didn't get sick
you didn't have diarrhea
i didn't have diarrhea once that trip
did you did you gloat over here the rest
of your family was like oh you're
[ __ ] weak ass
when you guys choose restaurants out
there how do you know which ones are
like in the clear and which ones are
like i don't know no if you go to any
nicer restaurant the service is always
really really great like india that's
the one thing like if you go to a a
hotel it'll be excellent
it's completely different like you'll be
at a five-star hotel and then across the
street will be a slum
i like that i want to go there
oh i have a question is uh
is there something that dictates whether
or not like the ladies have the red dot
or not like if they're married or it's
just this it's a cultural significant
thing they're they're all religious
significant they're all religious
you don't have to be religious now it
can be both fashion cultural and
religion do guys do it too
uh they they don't they won't wear it in
the traditional sense but like for
example like uh if they go to temple and
then come back they'll have the powder
on isn't it
it's i don't know what it is what about
the red dot thing i see like my friend's
ground yeah that's just a sticker oh
that's not that's not religious yeah for
her if your grandmother is wearing it
she's probably wearing it for religious
uh significance it'd be the equivalent
of anyone just like wearing a cross on
their neck what if gwen stefani wears it
what does that mean no that's just
appropriate
[Laughter]
but she did date an indian guy i had the
bass player the bass player was in here
yeah does it count
they're not married anymore right she's
married to what's i don't know i'm
asking for my white girlfriend because i
mean she's like she's like yo i have
enough japanese coming me i think i'm
pretty much japanese that's how she
phrased it yeah she was like i'm filming
so i'm like so i'm like one percent yeah
you know what at this point at this
point you can wear
anything yeah you could do whatever
that's fine you can you can do that
anyway yeah what type of japanese
traditions does she want to instill in
her life she was thinking about ritual
suicide
so that's the first one
harikari yeah harry carries what's the
difference between hari kaharikari and
seppuku for the same thing yeah ask him
some japanese [ __ ] uh that's the literal
translation i mean it's like cutting the
gut like uh yeah they mean two different
things but they're the same thing
basically so one's the ritual one's the
physical actual that's just the yeah
it's a real trend yeah which is the more
harakiri it's just hara is like gut
kitty is like cutting yeah and then
you know the art of killing yourself
basically that's the whole
judo and jiu jitsu sometimes are used
interchangeably in japan but then in the
us you think of brazilian jiu jitsu and
judo as olympic sport so then but it's
the same thing in japan japanese jiu
jitsu and judo are the same thing
if you write it out jiu jitsu so jitsu
just means technique technique dough is
way i learned that from naruto oh really
i knew that
karate karate dough karate jitsu yeah
it just means one is technique and
focuses on like more of the logical step
by step and then the other one is more
like the
the the spiritual encompassing yeah yeah
basically i get it what's your favorite
indian martial art
there's only there's one where is it
called dawson
all the internet is going to smash me on
do you guys remember that uh those two
guys that traveled the world and tried
tried different martial arts yeah
they go to india for the sword fighting
so that that's part of it and so it's
like based on a lot of animal movements
but the the idea is that that martial
art in conjunction with yoga made its
way
to the shaolin temple yeah whoa
that's how legend has it and then the
shaolin kung fu was born from that
they ripped off indian people and so
like as of course when
you know white people showed up they
make everything illegal yeah and so that
culture kind of disappeared
in buddhist and buddhist folklore
the shaolin temple was never like a
combative place it was just there's just
a name it's just like saying like
uh like eagle rock order just the name
of the place and then there was a
mysterious indian man that came and
taught them how to exercise yeah and the
exercise was the martial martial art and
then they started practicing it so much
that it became synonymous with that
tempo and you know that shaolin kung fu
made its way to okinawa
and then karate
original name was called chinese hands
and then the wu-tang clan
came and came to my house to do a music
video and then they dumped [ __ ] all over
the streets so as you can see this has
all come full
circle sharing of cultures
forever bro method man for life
you